do you think we humans would be able to
detect other intelligent beings other
conscious beings another way to ask that
is it possible that the aliens are
already here and we don't see them
meaning are we
very human-centric in our understanding
of one the definition of life to the
definition of intelligence and three the
definition of consciousness
the aliens are here they are just not
from outer space AI which is usually
stands for artificial intelligence I
think it stands for alien intelligence
because AI is an alien type of
intelligence it solves problems attains
goals in a very very different way in an
alien way from human beings and I'm not
implying that AI Came From Outer Space
it came from Silicon Valley but it is
alien to us if there are alien
intelligent or conscious entities that
came from outer space already here and
I've I've not seen every any evidence uh
for it it's not impossible but you know
in science evidence is everything well I
mean I guess instructive there's uh just
having the humility to look around to
think about living beings that operate
at a different time scale a different
spatial scale and I think that's all
useful when starting to analyze
artificial intelligence it's
possible that even the language models
the larger language models we have today
are already conscious I I highly doubt
it but I think
question of social norms because we
cannot prove Consciousness in anybody
except ourselves we know that we are
conscious because we are feeling it we
have direct access to our subjective
Consciousness we have we cannot have any
proof that any other entity in the world
any other human being or parents our
best friends we don't have proof that
they are conscious you know this is this
has been known for thousands of years
this is the card this is Buddha this is
Plato we we don't we can't have this
sort of proof what we do have is Social
conventions it's a social convention
that all human beings are conscious it
also applies to animals most people who
have pets I firmly believe that their
patch pets are conscious but a lot of
people still refuse to acknowledge that
about cows or pigs now pigs are far more
intelligent than dogs and cats in
according to many measures yet when you
go to the supermarket and and and buy a
a piece of Frozen pigment you don't
think about it as a conscious entity why
do you think of your dog as conscious
but not of the of the bacon that you buy
because you build a relationship with
the dog and you don't have a
relationship with the bacon Now
relationships they are they don't
constitute a logical proof for
Consciousness there are a social test
that the Turing test is a social test
it's not a logical proof now if you
establish a a mutual relationship with
an entity
when you are invested in it emotionally
you're almost compelled to feel that the
other side is also conscious
and when it comes down to Ai and
computers I think again I don't think
that at the present moment computers are
conscious but people are already forming
intimate relationships with AIS and are
therefore
almost irresists it's almost
irresistible they are compelled to to
increasingly feel that these are
conscious entities
and I think we are quite close to the
point when the legal system will have to
take this into account
that even though I don't think computers
have Consciousness I think we are close
to the point the legal system will start
treating them as conscious entities
because of this social convention